We knew Mando's scrappy little plan was going
to go poorly, but we didn't expect it to be
quite this much of a disaster.
In Chapter 7 of The Mandalorian, Mando's troubles
are stacked higher than ever before.
Titled "The Reckoning," the newest episode
of the Disney+ series proves that a reckoning
is definitely here, and its consequences have
had drastic effects on some of the show's
beloved characters.
Turn back now if you want to avoid some mudhorn-sized
spoilers.
Kuiil, the free Ugnaught, has fallen in his
last-ditch effort to secure the Child back
at the Mandalorian's ship, the Razor Crest.
Meanwhile, Mando, Cara Dune, and Greef Carga
are pinned down inside the offices of The
Client in Navarro, confronting the major antagonist
we've all been waiting for: Moff Gideon, a
former governor of the Empire.
Oh, and The Client is also dead, shot down
by the no-nonsense Moff Gideon.
And worst of all, The Child is in the hands
of the Empire, or what's left of it.
Moff Gideon shows us he's rigged the board
from the beginning, revealing that he's tapped
Mando's communications.
He's brought a force of Stormtroopers that
Mando can't possibly outgun, and there's no
enclave of other Mandalorians or bounty hunters
around to help him get out this time.
Moff Gideon is a different kind of villain.
While The Client spoke of Baby Yoda transactionally
and as a scientific specimen, Gideon, on the
other hand, describes him in different terms:
"It means more to me than you will ever know."
The stakes have always been presented as high
from the very first episode of The Mandalorian,
but only now are they beginning to be explained.
The Child, who has taken a backseat in most
of the Chapters so far, is using more of his
powers than ever before, but in this episode,
he carries out verifiable miracles with the
Force, and it's things we've never seen in
the canonical Star Wars universe ever before.
We were given a hint of Baby Yoda's strength
back in Chapter 2, when Mando has that nasty
gash in his arm.
Baby Yoda clambers out of his floating pram
and reaches for the wound, only to be picked
up and put back to bed.
Now we know why for sure: Baby Yoda can heal
significant wounds with the Force.
We can think of several instances across the
Skywalker saga in which that little trick
would have been extremely handy.
It's another game-changer, and creates more
questions than answers.
It is confirmed, however, that Mando has no
idea what the Force is.
Kuiil doesn't know it by name, but has heard
legends and rumors, which would make sense,
having been a former slave of the Empire under
Emperor Palpatine.
Cara Dune doesn't say what she knows either
way, despite having been Force-choked seconds
before, and being a decorated, high-ranking
veteran of the Rebellion.
Does she know more about the Force than she
wants to let on?
This Chapter also takes a quick moment to
shoot down at least one fan theory when Kuiil
expresses doubt that Baby Yoda is a clone,
or somehow grown by synthetic means.
If Baby Yoda is a genuine biological article,
where in the great, wide galaxy did he come
from?
And what's a "strand cast"?
By the end of the Chapter, it appears that
Mando has completely lost.
The Child is out of his possession, and he's
trapped with his only allies.
Except for a few Jawas who were really asking
for it, Mando has been very measured in doling
out his wrath upon others.
He often chooses not to kill, because he's
trying his best to be honorable.
He is, nonetheless, pretty angry and stressed
out all the time and has learned how to contain
it.
But what happens when Mando cares too much?
Many people have died because of his abrupt
impulse to be a dad, and the rising body count
shows no signs of halting.
There's a finale ahead with Chapter 8, but
it seems like it'll only bring more suffering
to Mando's feet.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about The Mandalorian
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.